[Musique]
monaco le soir du grand prix de formule
1 après la course c'est un autre défilé
qui commence celui des voitures de luxe
et de leurs riches propriétaires
direction les deux discothèques de monte
carlo
parmi les plus sélects de la riviera une
clientèle de milliardaires et de jet
setteur prêt à flamber on le patron de
cette boîte de nuit
richard borfiga c'est un énorme chiffre
d'affaires en perspective
ça peut faire c'est vraiment très très
très grosse abbott la soirée
exceptionnelle quand dans l'année pour
faire sauter la banque
il faut faire sauter les bouchons et
comme toujours dans les soirées huppées
c'est le champagne qui est en pôle
position pour qu'elle ne manque de rien
richard borfiga et son manager ont fait
le plein des centaines de bouteilles
presque uniquement des cuvées de
prestige
certains grands formats peuvent battre
des records
comme ces deux jéroboam de 3 litres à
1500 euros la bouteille
à ce tarif là surtout pas question de
passer inaperçu
[Musique]
feu d'artifice musique de star wars
direction le carré vip pour le premier
gros client de la soirée
[Musique]
ce monégasque de 18 ans s'il a déboursé
3000 euros ce n'est pas forcément par un
amour du champagne
mais avant tout pour faire mousser son
compte en banque
[Musique]
pas simple
le jeune monégasque a mis le feu aux
poudres c'est parti pour une surenchère
de champagne l'objectif c'est d'en
commander toujours plus que son voisin
de table pour épater la galerie
et à ce petit jeu certains sont prêts à
faire des folies
une soirée d'excès c'est exactement ce
que richard borfiga et son manager
espérait même 55 trois mille 3000 est
hélas comme l'a6 entre meetic mais pour
se faire remarquer à coup sûr il y à
encore mieux à sa cdc la route c'est la
rose c'est à dire c'est que quand on a
vendu ça on a fait un bon groupe mais
voilà il ya au total il ya pour eux
parce que son sort de 1000 euros les
trois vingt mille euros pour cette
bouteille de 6 litres plus d'un an et
demi le smic net pour une bouteille de
brut
certaines marques de champagne ont bien
compris pour une certaine clientèle plus
c'est cher plus ça se vend
[Musique]
plus c'est cher meilleur c'est moi je
n'aime que les choses les plus chères au
monde
champagne lamborghini ferrari et les
hommes bien sûr avec près de deux cent
mille euros de chiffre d'affaires en une
soirée
c'est un grand pays parfaitement réussie
pour richard borfiga
mais les grands gagnants de la soirée ce
sont surtout les quelques maisons de
champagne qui se partagent le marché des
cuvées de prestige goff clicquot don
perignon krug ruinart ou cristal des
noms qui font rêver et des prix qui font
tourner les têtes
quelles sont les recettes des grandes
marques pour s'imposer auprès des people
et des milliardaires qui at il vraiment
à l'intérieur de ces grands crus
pourquoi certains clients sont prêts à
toutes les folies pour s'offrir ces
bouteilles qui valent de l'or
[Musique]
nous sommes en champagne bien loin des
discothèques de la côte d'azur
c'est dans ses vignes que tout commence
en particulier pour l'un des crus les
plus célèbres du monde et les plus chers
le cristal de roederer son mathusalem
est vendu 20 mille euros en boîte de
nuit
c'est un peu grâce à jean baptiste
l'écaillon le chef de cave de la célèbre
maison champenoise
les grappes qui serviront à fabriquer le
fameux breuvage ne sont récoltés que sur
ces parcelles d'exception parmi les plus
chères au monde
donc ici on est dans un périmètre qui
est classée grand cru jusqu'au jusqu'à
la route là bas au dessus en aveugle
clicquot derrière il ya un énorme
vignoble une grosse partie de moët et
chandon également on a tous investi
ensemble c'est c'est dire que le raisin
était de la qualité un hectare de vigne
approche 1 millions d'euros
des vignes à un million d'euros
et ce n'est pas la seule explication aux
prix élevés du cristal
au centre de reims voici les caves de la
maison fondée au xviiie siècle on va
faire 10 heures ce matin pour
jean-baptiste les camions et les quatre
sommelier de la maison c'est l'heure de
la dégustation pour l'instant juste un
nom de code est pas de bulle pour le
futur champagne entre la récolte du
raisin et la mise en bouteilles
il faut au minimum 6 ans de
vieillissement en fûts de chêne et des
dizaines de dégustations comme celle ci
d'accord vous trouvez moi je trouve que
dans l'es19 un peu plus de minéralité
la c29 est bien aussi peut-être un peu
moins précise oh
pour jean baptiste l'écaillon c'est un
travail quotidien depuis plus de 20 ans
avec à l'arrivée un goût saluée par les
plus grands oenologues
il ya eu des gains de l'objectif c'est
de faire le meilleur le meilleur du
meilleur
on cherche la force on cherche la
recherche l'attention on cherchait
quelque chose extrêmement précis la
précision il faut que ce soit le
seigneur de la dégustation quand il faut
qu'il ressorte brion un vin d'exception
par son goût mais pas seulement
ce qui fait le prix de cette bouteille
c'est surtout l'histoire qui entoure sa
création
alors on va passer par ici qui est quand
même le trésor dans la maison à 12
mètres sous terre
14km de caves 51 mille bouteilles de
cristal et depuis un siècle
toujours le même geste
chaque jour les rumeurs bascula
bouteilles d'un quart de tour pour
éviter la formation du dépôt la
bouteille est remué à la main car elle
ne rentre dans aucune machine à remuer à
cause de sa forme très particulière
c'est la seule bouteille de champagne à
avoir le cul plat une exception que l'on
doit à un tsar de russie en 1876
alexandre ii à une exigence royal il ne
veut plus voir le même champagne que ça
court
il commande alors une cuvée
exceptionnelle à louis roederer son
fournisseur officiel pour son meilleur
vin rush choisi une bouteille en cristal
et accus plat une demande spéciale du
tsar un brin paranoïaque il craignait
qu'un opposant dissimule de l'explosif
dans le fond d'une bouteille classique
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la bouteille est en verre
mais elle conserve de cette époque une
notoriété internationale
voilà la boucle la boîte un petit rappel
alan fort de russie dont du tsar
alexandre ii
malgré ce rappel impérial la russie ne
représente aujourd'hui qu'une petite
part de marché sept bouteilles
commercialisées 180 euros se fait rare
dans toute l'europe
plus de la moitié de la production est
exportée aux états unis la commande qui
est en train de passer c'est une
commande de trois mille quatre cent
cinquante six bouteilles qui partent aux
états unis historiquement les états unis
est un gros marché de cristal les
américains raffolent
car la vieille marque française a
bénéficié d'un coup de pub inattendue il
des dizaines d'années fin des années 90
le champagne français fait une entrée
fracassante dans le milieu rappelle les
stars du hip hop en font un symbole du
bling bling et dans leur clip sulfureux
le vin de tradition vieilli six ans en
fûts de chêne n'avance plus vraiment des
plats raffinés
des images qui dope les ventes aux etats
unis
mais ce n'est pas franchement l'image de
marque que comptait promouvoir
l'héritier de la maison roederer
frédéric rouzaud 41 ans les douche au
champagne ce n'est pas vraiment sa tasse
de thé
il y a trois ans le pdg dénonce
l'utilisation de son vin délicat dans un
article anglais
il déclare ne pouvoir empêcher que les
rappeurs achète son champagne des propos
jugés racistes par les stars du rap
américain
moi j'ai exprimé simplement le fait que
effectivement le l'homme la manière
parfois dont dans certains clips vidéo
le le cristal servait d'arroseurs etc
bon voilà qu'en tant que vinificateur
élevé avec les soins gros con qu'on
comprenait pour faire notre champagne ça
nous voilà c'était pas forcément notre
mode de communication de consommation
les chefs de file du rap américain
décide alors le boycott du cristal et
quelques semaines plus tard ils jettent
leur dévolu sur un autre vignoble pour
le plus grand bonheur d'une petite
maison de champagne totalement inconnu
jusqu alors nous sommes à chigny les
roses près d'epernay
voici la maison de champagne en question
et son directeur commercial
philippe bienvenus vous savez où ça en
est sabrina pour la commande en ligne
d'après midi il y a trois ans c'est
comme s'il avait gagné au loto
grâce à cette bouteille doré frappé de
l'as de pique
c'est elle la nouvelle star des rappeurs
jeu les bienvenus se souvient avec
émotion de la première apparition de sa
bouteille dans ce clip de rap un
personnage débarque sur une plage avec
une mystérieuse mallette la suite
philippe adore d'un revers de la main la
star du rap djezzy va donner le coup de
grâce au cristal
voilà un clip à illies refuse
effectivement une bouteille cristal
roederer et il fait appeler une
bouteille effectivement armand de
brignac
et là vous allez voir
[Musique]
voilà
c'était la première apparition dans un
clip vidéo
armand de brignac c'était en 2006 alors
effectivement c'était un instant à c'est
assez magique et est quelque chose qu'on
l'avait jamais imaginé bien entendu dès
lors la marque c'est à la longueur de
clips même mariah carey semble très
inquiètes ce succès fulgurant
la presse du monde entier s'empare du
phénomène
philippe bienvenue doit répondre à des
centaines d'interviews
la marque vient à peine d'être créée en
partenariat avec une société américaine
rien de mieux que toute cette promotion
gratuite pour faire décoller les ventes
après avoir délaissé le cristal le
rappeur choisi une marque inconnue comme
son champagne de choix avec des
résultats surprenants
c'est une consécration intestat blement
alors c'est d'autant plus une
consécration qui effectivement on se
retrouve dans un monde que ce soit à la
maison
audrey roux ou parfois avec don pérignon
s'éteint c'est un monde dans lequel on
est heureux de d'être présents jean
louis
si la bouteille a tant plu aux rappeurs
c'est qu'elle concentre tous les
éléments du tape à l'oeil
à l'intérieur un vin haut de gamme mais
surtout un packaging sur mesure tout a
été étudié pour donner une impression de
grand luxe la couleurs clinquantes des
bouteilles et les étiquettes en est un
le coffret en bois laqué du nom de la
marque à l'emblème philippe bienvenue
n'a rien choisi au hasard
on a voulu quelque chose qui symbolise
en même temps la france et on l'a trouvé
cette idée l'as de pique parmi l'un des
symboles de la monarchie française
pour tout vous dire voilà c'est très
luxueux et c'était volonté à l'autre
toute façon on a réussi quelque chose
qui est facilement reconnaissable
mémorisable une bouteille voyante et un
prix qui ne passe pas inaperçu alors
c'est la bouteille brut qui est la
bouteille d'eau que l'on commercialise
le plus elle va être vendu en magasin
entre 250 et 300 euros ttc en boîte de
nuit vous aller la retrouver aux
environs de 900 euros
c'est sans doute un peu plus cher que
christiane oui oui effectivement
30% plus cher que son concurrent direct
et pourtant ça marche
aujourd'hui sa petite production de 50
mille bouteilles ne suffit plus à
satisfaire les commandes du monde entier
ici ça va partir sur les états unis
on a ici la hollande qui va partir on a
une palette un peu plus loin qui va
partir pour l'afrique du sud également
elle va voyager loin également partout
dans le monde là bas on est aujourd'hui
dans un peu plus d'une trentaine de pays
alors on pourrait citer le panama st
barth la croatie avec laquelle on vienne
démarré récemment la roumanie la
bulgarie et puis donc l'un d'eux qui
s'en va aujourd'hui voilà il ya deux ans
voilà absolument on est parti vraiment
de zéro de rien
avec 3 millions de chiffre d'affaires
l'an dernier cette réussite
spectaculaire en à peine deux ans on a
impressionné plus d'un
ils sont désormais nombreux à vouloir
exploiter le filon avec parfois les
idées les plus folles la dernière en
date mettre leur non pas sur la
bouteille mais dans la bouteille
au mois de mai dernier à cannes pendant
le festival du film du glamour des
actrices et des people du monde entier
sur la croisette
[Musique]
c'est le décor qui a choisi jean
christophe rousseau 38 ans pour faire la
promotion de son nouveau breuvage
c'est un endroit très médiatisé ya
beaucoup de gens et c'est connu dans le
monde entier donc se passe beaucoup de
choses à came c'est important d'y être
on vient bien évidemment chercher une
clientèle haut de gamme et une image
pour soigner son image
ce soir c'est sur son yacht de 28 mètres
de long que jean christophe rousseau va
présenter sa dernière trouvaille
ça s'appelle le luxe or une bouteille
d'apparence classique mais lorsqu'on la
gîte
une pluie de paillettes d'or pur 24
carats appareils
[Musique]
21h c'est parti pour l'une des soirées
les plus courues de la croisette pour
créer l'événement jean christophe ne
compte pas sur les rappeurs mais sur un
spécialiste des arts martiaux
[Musique]
mais impossible pour jean christophe
rousseau d'obtenir une photo avec jcvd
une coupe de champagne à la main
l'acteur belge est à la diète
l'acheteur et je mange que les nuls
programme noté très convenu d'un accord
2009 que je touche haras c'est beau ça
doit l'être pour l'instant et je mange
du chocolat
heureusement il reste les jet setteurs
et les milliardaires
140 invités triés sur le volet
exactement la cible que veut séduire
jean-christophe il part tenter sa chance
sur le pont supérieur autour du barça
curieuse boissons intrigue c'est bon en
plus oui c'est clair
simple et bien bon rappeur bling bling
c'est le festival de cannes c'est la
côte d'azur au début madame croyais que
c'était sale mais bon quoi penser qu'ils
avaient des saletés alors si tu n'as pas
vu ton verre avec des foyers soir à 50
ans à la chefferie
l'écart est déjà temps le régal c'est
joli ça peut rien ne l'est pas moins
les jours jean christophe rousseau oui
c'est moi nous n'avions pas d'accord je
suis très content j'ai des paiements via
l'e commerce
petit à petit on trouve très peu parce
qu'il faut savoir que c'est un produit
qui est très limité prat le sentiment
d'exception fait vendre les arguments de
jean christophe font mouche et par pays
commandez directement
c'est exceptionnel et c'est vraiment un
produit c'est encore nous qui n'est pas
partout on peut avoir les choses que pas
tout le monde
la voix a avancé sa a l'exclusivité à
l'erreur est second avec la nourriture
c'est ça l'aiderait lips
oh
boire de l'or certains ne sont pas
convaincus comme cette dame qui s'est vu
refuser l'entrée sur le yacht à la bombe
ou de champagne je viens d'un côté il y
avait des
l'étagé est pape faye est dedans mais
j'ai eu une chute comme un tegra 600
hors bilan de la nuit trois contacts
sérieux dans le gotha et quelques
commandes fermes
joe christophe est satisfait non c'est
fini pour ce soir on continue demain on
pour ce soir en ville ça suffit on a
donné ce qu'on avait à donner ma france
on va rentrer des débuts prometteurs
le succès de jean christophe est
d'autant plus étonnant qu'il n'ait pas
un professionnel du champagne
tout a commencé ici dans le 12e
arrondissement de paris un petit atelier
de restauration des miroirs des cadres a
priori rien à voir avec le champagne
[Musique]
donc là vous allez attaquer la dorure
caen lundi
la spécialité de jean christophe
rousseau c'est la dorure en particulier
celle des grands monuments
ça c'est toutes les grilles on a fait
toutes les grilles du château de
fontainebleau les grilles du château de
fontainebleau ou celle du palais royal à
paris
le problème c'est que la restauration
des monuments c'est une fois tous les 50
ans pour se diversifier cet ancien
publicitaire formé en école de
communication a eu l'idée de se lancer
sur le marché du champagne
le but était de marier le plus précieux
des métaux avec la plus noble des
boissons de façon à réaliser quelque
chose d'absolument unique
j'ai eu un flash visuellement et donc je
me suis dit que c'était et c'était
quelque chose à tenter
l'idée peut paraître saugrenue
pourtant il n'y a aucun risque ces
paillettes d'or sont utilisés en
pâtisserie donc on a effectivement voilà
le côté le côté très volatile côté magic
une petite pluie d'or
effectivement et d'un autre côté on est
sur quelque chose ici qui complètement
alimentaire donc et qui n'a pas de goût
il est complètement neutre un gramme
d'or alimentaire ça vaut à peu près
aujourd'hui à peu près 50 euros hors
taxes dans ce petit pot là il ya 0,3 g
maintenant ça c'est confidentiel
c'est secret ça fait partie du secret de
fabrication
ça pas possible selon notre estimation
il n'y aurait pas plus d'un dixième de
gramme par bouteille à peine 5 euros
d'or
mais pour ces quelques paillettes il
fait payer le prix fort environ 190
euros la bouteille dans le commerce
c'est 10 euros de plus qu'une bouteille
de cristal et pourtant c'est loin d'être
un vin haut de gamme
jean-christophe ne possède pas de vignes
il se contente de racheter les
bouteilles de ce producteur
[Musique]
pas une cuvée prestige mais un simple
brut vendu 27 euros en boutique
alors il a choisi le carte d'or qui est
le gros de classiques de la maison
comment ce brut et il transformé en
boisson de luxe mystère le producteur
tient à rester très prudent sur le sujet
nous ils nous achètent quelques cartons
de champagne et ensuite il fait sa
préparation dans ces locaux que je ne
n'ai jamais visité
j'ai vu qu'il y avait des paillettes
d'or à l'intérieur bon trouvé ça amusant
ça fait rigoler monfils qu'à dix ans
mais sinon je n'en sais pas plus pour
tenter d'en savoir plus il faut quitter
la champagne
direction la bourgogne à deux heures de
voiture
jean christophe a investi dans cet
entrepôt c'est ici qu'il change le
champagne en nord pas de fûts de chêne
pas de rumeurs seulement quelques
bureaux spéciaux il ya aussi une pièce
secrète que jean-christophe refuse de
nous montrer impossible de connaître sa
formule magique pour métamorphoser cette
palette de simples brut en produits
d'exception
[Musique]
donc
tout va se passer derrière en bas on a
effectivement nos machines
notre système qui est complètement
confidentielle c'est pour ça qu'on ne
peut pas aller plus loin
c'est un procédé unique au monde tout à
fait qui est très spécifique
quel est donc ce procédé unique au monde
on n'en saura pas plus en tout cas
lorsque la bouteille ressort elle n'est
plus verte mais transparente
le nouveau breuvage a perdu
l'appellation champagne
mais la plus grosse transformation c'est
le prix il a été multiplié par sept
fini le brut à 27 euros bienvenue au
luxe or vendu 190 euros en boutique et
aux alentours de 500 euros dans les
discothèques
un nouveau concurrent sérieux pour les
vrais champagne de luxe sur ce type de
marché
effectivement
le produit doit être cher pour être
crédible oui bien sûr pourquoi mais
parce que je veux dire on est jeune et
il ya des gens dans certains
établissements qui vont prendre la carte
et qui vont commander les bouteilles les
plus chers je dirais peu importe
finalement la qualité
d'ailleurs on sait très bien que sur la
plupart la plupart des marques de
champagne on est avant tout dans du
marketing pour justifier les prix élevés
de leurs bouteilles
les producteurs ont trouvé une astuce
ils en font des produits rares ils
mettent leurs bouteilles sur le marché
au compte gouttes
sur la côte d'azur certains ont trouvé
le moyen de contourner cette stratégie
de la pénurie en créant un marché
parallèle c'est le cas sur cette plage
privée de saint tropez un endroit où il
fait bon être vu quand on est people ou
jet setteur le patron douglas balech le
sait bien c'est grâce au champagne de
luxe qu'il réalise ses plus grosses
marges les naisseurs ça arrive
son obsession avant l'été c'est de faire
le plein des frigos pour lui la grosse
saison commence samedi prochain
d'abord un anniversaire un anniversaire
de
clients nous russe donc c'est une grosse
fête
donc on a tout commandé le rosé tout est
prêt maintenant il nous manque plus que
le champagne je fais comment vis tu va
pas tarder à arriver
ils veulent essentiellement pour la
soirée du cristal donc
cristal roederer la gelée commandé dans
mon voile pas tarder à me livrer pour la
livraison et je compte sur paul un jeune
tropézien de 19 ans voitures de luxe
chauffeur paul est ce qu'on appelle un
ramasseur sa mission dénicher les
champagnes réputé introuvable pour le
compte des professionnels de la nuit
moyennant une bonne commission
paul est toujours très discret comme
toujours la livraison se fait à l'abri
des regards et par camionnette banalisée
à l'intérieur une vraie fortune il ya 30
une trentaine de ge wang cristal et à
peu près autant de deux magnums c'est
très bon et il y en a ici pour cent
vingt mille euros
[Musique]
j'ai emmené tout ce qu'il faut tiens ça
c'est les sas et dwan mes amis oui les
acheter en france et aux états unis sera
vite aller chercher les bouteilles
jusqu'aux états unis la pratique n'est
pas illégal mais les maisons de
champagne des tests car ce marché
parallèle permet de contourner le
rationnement qu'elle impose le petit
business des ramasseurs comme pole
échappe à tout contrôle mais sans lui ce
serait la pénurie en france
je passe toujours par le réseau
parallèle puisque il trouve les flacons
quand il fait très rapidement mais pas
de conditions non il n'y a pas de
conditions moi c'est un peu plus cher
c'est un peu plus cher sinon les pas de
conditions particulières plus cher car
il faut payer les droits de douane et
surtout la commission de paul en pleine
saison elle atteindrait les 15000 euros
par mois au final les bouteilles
reviennent presque trois fois plus cher
au patron de la plage mais vu le prix de
revente d'une telle bouteille 12000
euros en moyenne
ça reste une excellente affaire donc ça
c'est du camp samedi prochain prochain
[Musique]
130 clients on compte sur paul le
ramasseur dans son carnet d'adressés les
endroits les plus huppés de la cote sa
part monaco
dans un champ paul a prévu de livrer
plus d'un millier de bouteilles cet été
le champagne devrait couler à flot dans
les clubs et sur les plages françaises
de quoi alimenter le juteux marché du
champagne près de 5 milliards d'euros
chaque année